i worked in a dental office it's a
business
i'm telling you yeah you know what was
that was the craziest thing when i
worked there i realized that just like
comedians
they were there was good dentists there
was hacks
and it was it's so true dude there was
one [ __ ] guy
this this dude like he was he always
vacationed in florida and he just was
trying to get to that vacation and he
just [ __ ]
he would just [ __ ] it you know if you
had two cavities suddenly you had five
and he's just going to town it's just
like the same thing with the guy at
midas you just need the muffler and he
wants to replace it from the block
all the way to the bay got a busted
aspirated tube you see the shoes he's
jabbing it with a screwdriver
he was doing that with people's teeth
well that's what's [ __ ] up about it
that's a part of your body correct
correct
removing that's why the dentist is more
[ __ ] up than the mechanic because at
least the mechanic is
[ __ ] with an inanimate object but the
dentist is like
well the doctor is like let's just [ __ ]
with this guy
you know [ __ ] him yeah i gotta go to
florida i gotta get the floor no you
take an oath
basically that you won't do that [ __ ]
that you're gonna uphold
whatever whatever medicine you're in
whatever you're not gonna do stuff like
that but you know i've always been for
more dental oversight people do
dude i went to a dentist out here and
they said you know you're grinding your
teeth you need a night guard
and they gave it to me and they didn't
do the impression right and next thing
you know my [ __ ] jaw
was like i would yawn i'd have to like
pop it back in
you know it's funny i so [ __ ] hate
like just
phone calls and being like yeah i came
in on this day and then this happened
that i just
i just ignore i just threw it out i
never bitched
and it kind of just went away but i
could have sued right
i could have sued got one of those
dental chairs in my [ __ ]
living room yeah just laid back watching
the nhl network
always asking your wife for the spit cup
honey get me that [ __ ] spit cup i
want in the suit
[ __ ] with my dog with that ear thing
yeah
i didn't have a great time but i didn't
i didn't tie up the courts with that
frivolous suit
my dentist wears hawaiian shirts they
all do